well nevada's politicians are lending a  helping hand to our community  today several prominent democrats  gathered in north las vegas at a food  bank  and as you know food insecurity has  really risen during the pandemic  senator jackie rosen says seeing  neighbors helping each other  really lift spirits we are so lucky  that so many businesses faith-based  community our churches our synagogues  our mosques  small businesses everybody's pitching in  to help their neighbors and friends and  in this  time of uh of incredible hardship for  people  nevada's congressional delegation has  been holding events all across the  valley this week as you see their  representative stephen horsford  filling the back of an suv they're  trying to get support for the new  coronavirus relief bill